- You're gonna see me get
into a bunch of carnival games
like darts, pool, hockey, and basketball.
You're gonna see me do
a podcast with Aubrey.
And then most importantly,
you're gonna see me rock this theater
in a Q and A session for the ages.
(techno music)
(cheering)
You got your perspective.
- [Announcer] Gary Vee!
- I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat music)
That really stopped me dead in my tracks
and I'm gonna tell you why.
I'm obsessed with perspective.
I genuinely believe you find
what you're looking for.
If you are looking for bad
right now, it's a piece of cake.
If you're looking for good
I'm just asking what the
fuck are you looking for?
(upbeat music)
- Are you almost through?
- Yeah, man.
- No, I know.
I fucking had to pull it back in.
- Pleasure to meet you, man.
- Would've got kicked out.
- I was listening to you
this morning.
- Thank you, bro.
- We were talking 'bout it,
his mom said--
- Literally she tagged me in
a video of yours this morning.
Like, randomly, I had never
seen anything like it,
and I was like, what
are the chances of that?
- [Gary] That's crazy.
What's her name?
- Michelle.
She works for RE/MAX.
- [Gary] Let's surprise her.
Michelle?
- Oh, you want me to FaceTime her?
- Michelle?
- Yeah.
- Michelle, timing is everything.
Everything.
She'll be blown away.
- Thanks, man.
- Can I get a pic real quick?
- Yeah.
- Here.
- Yeah, I got you, man.
- Appreciate it, dude.
- Man, I'm all nervous and shaking.
- Thank you, sir.
(laughing)
- Say something to Snap.
- Yo, don't tell 'em.
Shh.
You know we're doing it.
- Woo!
(upbeat music)
- What would you like to happen?
Like, it's kinda like working
out or like eating properly.
Ironically, ironically,
not a lot changes.
It just becomes, you're
getting the results
and putting out the work.
Literally, you're one
day away from a video
or piece of content really changing
the outcome of the growth.
But the reality is,
even if you don't have
something go bananas,
the reality is that one, two,
three pieces of content a day
keeps pulling another block,
another block, another block.
Right?
The way you get a real muscular body
is by putting the work in
the gym every single day.
There is no shortcuts.
So let me ask you this,
how often are you posting on Instagram?
- [China Mac] I post like
two, three times a day.
- So to me one of the things
to just debate is is it four?
Right?
It is actually just four?
Because the reality is, for
me it's four, by the way.
That's my number.
And I always think
about, should it be five?
That to me is one place where to answer
your question directly
is you can get bigger
by putting out more content.
The other question
becomes what other things
are you putting out?
So where are you,
obviously I see what
you're doing on Instagram,
where are you when it comes
to LinkedIn or Twitter
or podcast or things of that nature?
Where are you on that?
- [China Mac] Well, I'm.
Hello?
- Yeah, sorry, an alarm went off.
Go ahead.
- [China Mac] Where I'm at
is at Instagram and YouTube.
But then you get, I didn't
grow up using this stuff.
So, just me handling Instagram alone,
it's like, you know that's
crazy for me, right?
And Instagram and YouTube,
and I come from prison.
So, we're not used to really opening our--
- I get it, I get it.
- For me, I can do this much.
- I get it.
You know, it's funny,
you'll appreciate this.
You know, I was born in Russia, right?
And grew up in a household
with two parents that lived
their entire life in Russia.
And like, the last thing you
do in communism is share.
So I understand the
concept of, even for me.
It was a process, as an extrovert.
It was a process.
But the reality is,
you're doing it, right?
Like, what's cool about you, for me,
in the way you're talking to me right now,
is, but I'm from prison,
I didn't grow up with this stuff,
we don't share, is
normally what people say
when they're not doing anything.
The fact that you're already doing,
now it's just chipping away daily.
Listen, you need to be doing Twitter.
I'm telling you right to your face.
It's gonna work for you
and your style of content.
I honestly think you should be
putting out content on LinkedIn
about one thing, specifically.
How to be successful when
people re-enter the world
from prison and how companies
can be using those in--
That level of adversity is
actually a remarkable advantage
if it's manifested properly, right?
So, I think there's places
that you have permission
to go to that I can't go to.
You know, I can't, from a
first party point of view,
talk about what it's like
or what my thoughts are.
I don't have enough context
about what's happening
in that system, so the answer
to your question is, more.
(upbeat rock music)
Four times a day on Instagram.
And Twitter, and I know you
didn't grow up using it,
but you figured out how to use Instagram.
You're gonna figure
out how to use Twitter,
you're gonna figure out
how to post on LinkedIn.
That's just real.
That's who you are.
You've already proven.
'Sup, bro?
- How you doing?
- Too well.
- Good.
- Good to see you.
- Good to see you, too!
- What's going down?
- Not too much.
Come on in, everybody.
- What else is going on?
- Not too much.
We got some carnival games set up.
We're gonna go around and fuck around,
and throw darts and--
- Yeah?
Nice.
- Knock pool balls around
and play Sauce.
- Let's go.
- You ever play Sauce?
- What's Sauce?
- It's like a little hockey game.
- I'm ready.
- (laughing) All right.
(upbeat rock music)
- I don't think I've fuckin' thrown a dart
in like, fucking--
(laughing)
Jesus fucking Christ.
- I mean, I mean!
(laughing)
(cheering)
- That's real good for
the first dart I've thrown
in fucking 600 years!
(laughing)
(scoffs)
God, those first two
were fucking legit, I'm
very happy with that.
All right, one, zero.
- [Aubrey] Oh, damn.
- Mm-hmm, that's good, Aubs.
That's good, Aubs.
Uh-huh, I like where this is headed.
Yep!
(bell chimes)
One, one.
(laughing)
The road team puts one up on the board.
- This is for all the fucking marbles.
- Oh, so we're playing, this is it?
Two out of three?
Okay, all right, understood.
- Oh.
- Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm.
- That was, that was not
what we're looking for here.
- I get it.
- That's not what we're looking for.
(laughing)
- That's not what we're--
- Okay.
- That might be enough.
There's room.
There is a lot of room.
- [Man] I am the target.
(groans)
I am the target.
(screams)
(laughing)
- Aw, fuck, I think you won!
- I don't--
- Fuck!
- No!
No, dude.
- [Gary] Oh, dude.
- [Aubrey] That's the one.
- It is, isn't it?
- That's the one.
- Let's go!
- (laughing) Damn it!
- I started out so strong!
- [Gary] Let's go!
(smooth bass music)
- Well, you know, there we go.
(audience laughing)
- Well, that was just a practice shot.
- There we go.
- Get in there.
(groans)
- Nice.
- All right.
- [Gary] Super glide.
- Oh.
- Very good.
- I cut it.
- God, I have not
fucking played pool ever.
(laughing)
(intense guitar music)
(groans)
That fucking hurt.
- [Man] Same try.
(groans)
- Fuck.
- [Aubrey] This could be our day.
It might just be.
- We might miss
the conference.
(laughing)
- Get in!
- Nice shot.
(bell dings)
Nice shot.
- Jeffrey?
- Break out Lucille.
(audience laughs)
- Ooh, let's go!
(bell dings)
Be careful, Nick Dio.
Fucking gonna Minnesota Fats this shit.
(laughing)
(bell chimes)
- [Aubrey] What if I just
get swept and all I can--
- [Man] Who cares? (mumbling)
- [Gary] That's gonna be
really bad for your brand.
- [Aubrey] Oh, absolutely.
That's not gonna be good.
- Nick Dio, did you see that?
(laughing)
- I'm slightly impressed.
- You're slightly
impressed with that, right?
I just have good hand-eye coordination,
so it makes me dangerous at all times.
That's what happened in darts.
(bell chimes)
(laughing)
That's what it is.
(bell dings)
This is a tough one.
Good shit.
- Woo.
- Good shit, Aubs.
- [Aubrey] Thank you, sir.
- You were worried there for a second,
you needed that one.
- You were fucking shit up, too.
All right.
- All right.
- [Aubrey] We carry on.
I redeemed the family.
- The family is super pumped.
The collective sigh in this
room was like, thank God.
(laughing)
Thank God, we're not
going out of business.
(laughing)
Holy shit.
- Aw, shit.
- This is fucking cool.
(upbeat music)
I don't even know what, what is this game?
- [Aubrey] This game is called Sauce.
- Sauce.
- So, that's a real hockey puck, I mean,
real hockey sticks.
- Okay, I'm in deep shit here.
(laughing)
- So, it's based on the
idea of a saucer pass.
- Okay.
- So you have--
- I don't even know what the fuck that is.
(laughing)
- I'll show you.
- Okay.
- You gotta get it in the air,
and then if you get it in the little goal,
it's three points.
If you get it in the big mat.
So, it's three points in here,
one point in there.
- Yep.
- And you can't bounce it in.
It has to either hit the lap.
- Okay.
- Or it goes straight in.
- And so, the sauce, the key is
you gotta roll it across the--
You gotta roll it from the
bottom of the stick across.
Like that.
- Do you have to do that?
Or is that, like, a good
way to get it in the air?
- [Aubrey] That's a good
way to get it in the air.
- [Gary] I understand.
- Is to like, roll it.
So, that would've been a one-pointer.
- Okay.
- And then we go kinda,
we go to, like, fucking--
- 11?
- Yeah, 15.
- 15, all right.
Let's go.
(intense music)
- Plus first try.
- Understood.
All right.
- All right.
- That hit the ground.
Zero sauce, no sauce.
- No sauce.
- Dead sauce.
That's a little high.
All right, that was good.
- Fuck.
All right.
- All right, one point.
(bell dings)
(laughing)
- You're not even here.
- All right.
- [Aubrey] We should
get a goalie back there,
get some fucking gloves and shit?
(laughing)
- Woo!
- All right.
I'm gonna win this.
(laughing)
Seriously.
That was too good for
the first three shots.
I feel confident.
Feeling confident.
(bell dings)
- Two.
- Three nothing.
- Three nothing, all right.
- [Gary] It's a big lead.
It's a big lead in Sauce.
- Ooh, goal posts!
- That was big.
- Goal post!
- That was the, right here, Aubs.
That was the opening I needed.
That goal post got me hype.
Let's go.
- Nice!
On the board.
(laughter)
- Fuck!
- Woo!
Ooh!
The three pointer.
That one's good.
- That fucking hurts.
- Does anybody know the six toss rule?
Do I have to get it
exact, or can I go over?
- I think you have to go exact.
- [On-Looker] I think
you have to go exact.
- That's what I remember, playing Sauce.
- So, if I get it in the little goal,
then I go back to what?
- One!
- Zero.
- Seven.
- Zero!
- [Gary] Seven sounds right, actually.
Sounds right.
In the middle!
Oh.
(laughing)
In the middle!
Yeah!
Let's go!
- [Aubrey] Fucked up!
- I love Sauce.
Seven, one!
Seven, one.
Let's go.
That was huge.
- Another one in the middle.
- Ooh.
(bell chimes)
Fuck, you're so zoned in, though.
This is just a foregone conclusion.
I gotta get my shit together.
Uh huh.
Here's the problem right
now with us playing Sauce.
I'm gonna be here for the
next fucking four hours
practicing Sauce.
(laughter)
Let's go.
- Nice!
(bell dings)
- Woo, that's a three!
- [Gary] Things are getting interesting!
- It ain't four.
- [Gary] That's a lot of momentum.
Ooh, the post!
I love the fucking post!
The post has been my friend.
- [Aubrey] All right, all right.
10, five.
Nice, nice.
(bell dings)
All right, I gotta get two.
(clapping)
- Right in the fucking middle.
(groans)
(bell dings)
- I'mma go left side, left side.
- Nope, ground.
Right in the fucking middle.
- You're my guy, right here.
- Right in the middle.
- [Aubrey] Up for a fucking fifth.
Oh!
- Oh!
(applause)
Hanging on for dear life.
(laughter)
What's it, 14--
- Eight?
- Nine?
Nine.
- Was it nine?
Oh, God!
One more, give me one last chance.
I have nine, I can three it and two it.
I got it.
Give me one last prayer!
Yes!
- It's intimidating, not trying to get it
in the dead center.
(sighs)
- Fuck!
(laughs)
Just rippin' em.
Fucking Sauce.
- It went right up.
- Right in the fucking middle.
- No!
Whoa!
(laughs)
- Good shit.
- God damn it!
(laughs)
This is such a good idea.
I'm gonna start bringing
people to (mumbles)
to play games that I play all the time.
(laughing)
And the other person's never played.
Such a good idea.
- [Man] Let's go shoot some hoops, man.
- All right, let's go shoot hoops.
God, I haven't been on since the--
Oh, you weren't there!
Did you hear about that?
- I saw the video.
- Holy shit.
(men yells)
(intense music)
(laughs)
- [Man] You all right?
(yelling slowed down)
- I haven't played since.
I haven't shot a basketball
in like, forever.
(Swish by DKIRK)
- Stop.
♪ Throw the cash ♪
♪ Make it swish ♪
♪ Like a free ball ♪
- Way to get that.
♪ Let my arm hang down ♪
♪ Let it free fall ♪
♪ And I got this on my own ♪
♪ I ain't need y'all ♪
♪ Always gotta pay your dues ♪
- He's such a good person.
♪ It ain't free, dog ♪
♪ Pop respect on a nigga knee, yeah ♪
♪ I said all my dogs real ♪
♪ That's the only breed, yeah ♪
- 100%!
♪ Hey, we the total package and delivery ♪
♪ Got open doors for us, chivalry ♪
- Let's go.
- [Aubrey] Free throws?
- Yes.
I'm a bad free throw shooter.
(chatter echoes)
Sounds good.
(laughs)
You've gotta use everything you've got.
We need all these different variables.
(applause)
- [Man] Here we go.
- No!
No!
Couldn't feel good.
(bell chimes)
- [Aubrey] All right, three two.
(sigh)
(bell chimes)
- [Aubrey] Couple minutes here, Gary!
- Two minutes, Gary!
(groan)
Yeah!
- Wow, bro.
- God, I wanted that bad!
I wanted that bad!
I came out so confident.
(laughs)
Yes!
Good to see you, bye bye.
- Bye, guys.
- Bye, Aubrey.
- [Director] Okay Gary, that's like your
number one superfan.
- That's awesome, that's so sweet.
- [Female] She's also greatest.
- All my fans are greatest.
(laughs)
You know, usually when I go on podcasts
or things of that nature,
I'm like trying to answer the questions.
I'm thinking, I've
already done it once here.
I'm listening, so I'm
thinking of new things to say
that really stop me dead in my tracks.
And I'm gonna tell you why.
I'm obsessed with perspective.
Like, I genuinely believe you find
what you're looking for.
If you are looking for bad right now,
it's a piece of cake.
If you're looking for good right now,
it's piece of cake.
I'm just asking you, what
the fuck are you looking for?
Like please, it's just
a very simple question.
And by the way, I hate--
In a lot of ways, I hate the way I talk.
Because it's super simple
and I'm sitting right now
thinking about the kid
who's listening to this
and she or he is in her room right now,
ear pods in, listening to this.
And they're miserable because
their dad's an alcoholic
or their mom's this or like real shit.
You know, like tough stuff.
And they're like, ugh, fuck you.
It's not that simple.
Yet it is.
You know, one thing I don't do well
is talk about my problems.
Which manifests in many ways.
It manifests in being taken for granted.
In my real life and in my collective life,
my outward life.
I have fucking problems.
I've got lots of problems.
Real ones, I grew up
with lots of this stuff.
Like lots and lots and lots of stuff.
I just am not capable of going into it.
Like, I don't get going.
I can't get there.
And so, one of the things
that I try to remind kids,
take me out of the equation.
Like don't even use me when I'm
saying these things for you.
If you know of one person
that has ever gotten
to a happy place that dealt
with your circumstance,
there is a blue print.
The end.
There have been people--
Night Train Lane.
Legendary football player was thrown
in a dumpster the second he was born.
Went on to be one of the
great football players
of all time, dated every
actress in the game,
was Redd Foxx's body guard.
Iconic gentleman.
Dumpster.
Like, there's all sorts of circumstances.
- [Aubrey] Yeah, and we all
have our fucking dumpsters.
- Everybody's got a dumpster, bro.
And you know who has dumpsters?
I apologize.
You know who has dumpsters?
Kids that have too much.
You wanna talk about who I'm
actually getting hit up by?
It's not the kid in the hood
that saw me with Gunna and
they think I'm cool now.
They're like, how do I get out of the--
It's kids that are trust
fund babies who are sick.
Listen, and I know this,
I never judge somebody that
comes from a shitty circumstance.
I'm a cheerleader, I'm
an underdog guy, right?
I cheer that.
I meet you and we're friends and then like
we're at a dinner party and
my friend comes over and goes,
you know who that is right?
Like that's the grandson
of fuckin' Howard Hughes.
I immediately judge that person.
Nothing that person ever
achieves, I'll give credit to.
That's me, that's actually
how I see the world.
I will not fully give
credit to my own children
because of that reason.
I'm being very transparent here.
I would much rather, in
a world of the internet
where the internet
doesn't care who you are.
I'd much rather in 2019
come from too little
than come from too much.
Not in
1984.
'Cause there was no internet
and all those relationships
and all that money
really mattered.
But I believe, that we're
living in a very funny time.
Where clout, reputation,
work ethic, a lot of
different things are starting
to be put on pedestals.
Not just money, and earning
your keep and who you are
and what you're giving to the world.
I think we're living in a
very interesting transition.
- [Aubrey] Well, whatever you have it
changes your start position
and that can be overwhelming.
It's all about what you
do with what you have
from where you begin.
- And by the way, it's
all perspective, right?
For me, as someone who takes
so much pride in the process,
I wouldn't have wanted to
start on third and a half base.
Somebody else listening right now is like,
I'm pretty cool with it.
Pretty pumped--
And you know, that's fine.
- [Aubrey] If you start
on third and a half base,
you better fucking hit it 500 feet.
- By the way, here's
where it's really fun.
Here's where it gets super interesting.
Or not.
And guess what, who
the fuck are all of us?
(laughs)
You're on third and a
half base and you end up
on second and a half base and what?
And this is actually the punchline.
Actually, if somebody's
listening right now.
If you're somebody who's like 50, 60, 70
and you start on third and a half base
and ended on second and a half base,
but you're pumped as
fuck and happy for real,
please email me.
Like I just wanna know that insight
because I actually think
it's the reverse of me.
Excuse me, I think it's similar to me.
Which is what actually happens
when you can calibrate judgment?
I believe one of the
biggest reasons that I'm
one of the forefront faces of all this
is 'cause I can handle the judgment.
Do you know how much hate I have?
There's a video right now of a young woman
doing a motivational speech.
She crushed it, it's going
a little viral on Twitter.
I'm getting destroyed by the comments.
They're like, yeah fuck that Gary V guy.
I know that's who you're
fricking making fun of.
That hurts.
And most people are folding their chairs
when they get judged like that.
I'm not because I know
everyone of those people
who said that, have never met me.
I can handle judgment
if you don't know me.
If Caleb and Nick Dio
thought I was a dick face,
then I would have a real problem.
- [Aubrey] Well then
it's a truer reflection.
Even still it's not the truest.
- Correct.
- [Aubrey] Like we ourselves
are the truest mirrors.
If we actually are fair
and actually looked
without the biases that we all bring
then we are the only ones.
I mean Body Miller was
someone who taught me that.
- So true.
- [Aubrey] He was like, if
someone pumps your tires,
they don't know you.
If they congratulate you on that.
Like he would get congratulated
on finishing a race
and he didn't like the race,
he couldn't take that.
He's like, well I didn't
fucking ski at my best.
And he would ski his best sometimes,
crash or not finish well,
and everyone would be like, oh sorry man.
He'd be like, fuck you, man.
Like, I fucking skied my best.
Do you know what I mean?
- Honestly, that just got
me fired up about Body.
I'm the same way, man.
Like, it's unbelievable how
I do not take the accolades
and I do not take the hate.
I'm just fucking in the middle.
I'm in my own head.
- [Aubrey] It's really a
reflection of who's saying it.
It's not really a reflection
it's their projection.
- I'll be honest, you'll appreciate this.
It doesn't even go that far, bro.
Honestly, I've got ear pods in 24/7.
Can't hear shit.
(laughs)
From my mom to a stranger,
just don't hear it.
I don't know what else to tell you.
I'm in a very fucking place,
a very interesting place on this.
You know what it's driven by?
Empathy, I know they don't know me.
They don't know me.
They just can't fucking begin to know me.
Like I hate Scotty Pippin.
I don't know Scotty Pippin.
So, I understand it.
I fucking hate Scotty Pippin.
I despise Tom Brady.
And I actually know a lot
of people that know him
and it sounds like he's
a fairly solid dude.
I still fucking hate him.
(laughs)
So like, if I'm willing to do that,
then everyone's willing to do that.
- [Aubrey] And everyone gets permission.
- But I think judgment is on tilt.
Judgment is like fucking--
I'm telling you man,
that's all we're doing now.
People are just fucking hot
taking each other 24/7, 365.
Casting judgment, scale
judgment is at tilt.
Judgment has momentum.
Judgment is the undertone right now.
And honestly, I wanna push so against it.
Or calibrate it.
- Yeah.
- I've lost so much momentum
in judging somebody,
you can't imagine it'll last five years.
Everybody does it, it's a human trait.
But like, mine doesn't get going anymore.
Like, I'm just like, I don't know anything
about anybody.
That was awesome.
(applause)
I think people are
gonna really enjoy that.
- Fuck yeah.
- That was a good one.
- Yeah, that was sick.
- Love it.
(somber music)
(electronic music)
- This song.
This song got a second wave of like life
when I was in high school.
- [Caleb] It's probably ready
for another one then, right?
- It might be.
♪ I've gotta know right now ♪
- [Nick Dio] Who is this?
Who does this song?
- Meatloaf.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- [Nick Dio] That makes sense.
- I highly recommend you don't put that
in part of the vlog.
You're gonna get destroyed.
- [Caleb] Oh yeah, well now I'm going to.
(laughs)
(mumbling)
(whistles)
♪ Takin' time away ♪
- [Caleb] Even worse, my visual of it
is when he was a coach,
a guest coach on American Idol.
(laughs) Yeah, that's going in too.
- Did you know Gary hosted Ms. America,
or was a judge rather?
(laughs)
- I judged Ms. America.
Clip.
- A chance to add one more contestant.
As the sixteenth semi-finalist so.
- I will never forget that call.
- This is early.
- Five years ago.
- Yeah.
- Hello?
Hey Gary it's (mumbles).
Look we're seriously considering--
We're trying to expand a little bit
and we're looking for
somebody that's social.
Would you consider judging Ms. America?
Let me think about it.
Yeah!
And it was amazing, it was amazing.
It was just really like a fun thing.
It was especially fun for me
because when we first--
When we lived in Edison,
one of the most American things for me
is when we made it, is when we moved to
the suburbs in Edison.
And one of the best
things we did with my mom,
me and my sister, from like 1982 to 1988
was like award shows.
It was a big thing.
Like we'd all get in my mom's bed
and we would watch and we'd try to guess.
Like award shows, any of them.
The Grammy's the (mumbles).
And then like things like Ms. America.
So like, that's why it was so fun for me.
Ms. America 1984 through 1988
laying in my mom's bed with my sister
watching that competition
and trying to guess who won
is a core early American
story to my heart.
So, I'm here because I'm selfish.
Because it meant
something to me growing up
and I thought it would mean
a lot for me and my family,
my sister, mom specifically,
that I'm here.
I was correct, they're both
very emotional excited.
And I'm happy to do that.
I always think in terms
of when I do something,
when I call my mom, what does she think?
- Yeah.
- You know?
What does she think of like
look how far we've come?
Right, ya know?
- That's cool.
- That's why (beep)--
You have to beep my face
if you do so use it.
Ooh that's heavy for me.
The sneaker was crazy but this is--
- Unreal.
Smells like a college dorm room.
Right?
So, we're just about to get going.
Look at this beautiful theater, Caleb.
Look at just like this old school shit
that I like so much.
Anyway, you know, thousand
people in the theater
in Austin, Texas.
I have a very funny
feeling I'm about to go
completely off the fucking rocker
because the energy of more people
always gets me to a
totally different place.
So, super psyched.
And then from here, rushing very quickly,
as you guys know 'cause you
watch a lot of my content,
I don't tend to go private but I gotta get
in a private plane because
I gotta be in Nashville
tomorrow morning right
early, bright and early.
A key note in Nashville.
I gotta run home 'cause
tomorrow's May 3rd,
one of my favorite days of the year,
my mom's birthday.
So I gotta rush home, give love there
and get into the weekend.
So it's been a pretty intense
pretty intense fucking week even for me.
Like, fly to San Francisco, red eye back.
Go right into work, all day 11:15.
Wake up at 3:00am, private
flight to Ohio with a client.
At 3:30 in the morning,
which is the earliest flight
I've ever taken.
Land, quickly catch a
flight from here to--
From Ohio, Columbus to here in Austin.
Now rolling hardcore this whole day.
Land in Nashville tonight at midnight.
Go at 7:00am.
Like it's perpetual fucking motion.
When you're in it, when
you're one with your thing
it sounds intense coming out of my mouth,
but it's easier than sitting
through first class science.
- [Aubrey] Give it up for Gary Vaynerchuk.
(applause)
- [Gary] What up, what up?
- Hi Gary, this is my
first time coming but
I'm a high school student.
So, I'm gonna graduate in June.
But I always have a plan to do,
but my parents they don't want
me to give myself a chance.
They always want me to go to college,
and I try and ask them for
time to like do something.
They want to see the result
of what I'm doing quickly.
They're always like forcing
me to go to college.
And stuff and they said like,
if I really want to do my own thing,
they want me to do college
and at the same time
work on my plan.
And at the same time
also want me to help them
with their business.
And I said I couldn't do that.
So what would be advice you would give me?
- You should go do your own thing.
- But like, my surrounding,
they're forcing me to do
what they want me to do
instead of giving me a chance.
- But they're not in charge.
They're only in charge if
you're using their home
and their money.
- Okay and plus, my mom said
that I am disappointing her
because of my choice.
- Of course, because she's
using psychological pressure
for you to do what she wants.
(applause and cheers)
The only thing you have to figure out is
if they have any leverage.
The only leverage they
have is money, shelter,
and psychological warfare.
(laughter)
- I'm living with them, so yeah.
- [Gary] What's that?
- I'm living with them so.
- Well, if you're gonna
want to do your own thing,
you're gonna have to move.
Here's my big thing with kids.
As you can tell, I'm very pro you.
But if you're gonna go do this thing
that's disappointing them,
then you can't take from them either
because then you're being spoiled.
So, if you feel so
passionate about this thing
that you wanna go do, go do it.
But don't expect them to support it
because they don't believe in it.
- Yes, they don't believe in it.
- So, go stick it in their face.
(applause and cheers)
- Okay.
- Right?
Let me tell you one thing about parents,
and this is very common,
they may be upset now but
if you go and pull this off
they will not be disappointed
and more importantly
if you go and try this, deep down one day,
they'll tell you secretly
that they're not disappointed.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
- I wanna thank you because
you inspired me to help
my dad market his business.
You really inspired me to go back
and get with the family
and help them upgrade.
But also, I have a barbecue podcast.
(cheering)
I just broke 10k on Instagram.
(mumble) This new thing I'm
trying to attempt at vlogs
and what do you suggest
for someone who's trying
to be media (mumble).
- You got it.
Thank you.
I'll lead with this.
We've gone very high level here tonight.
Let me go very tactical.
LinkedIn, right this minute, is acting
the same exact way that
Facebook in 2009, 10, and 11
was working.
You could post about anything,
not just business stuff
and the organic reach is ridiculous.
I highly recommend that
every single person tomorrow
puts their first post on LinkedIn in
video or written form.
I think you will be
astonished by what happens.
(applause)
Austin!
I gotta go.
It's true, it's true, it's true.
Let's go bro.
- I love you!
- I love you back.
- Gary!
- Yes!
Okay, let's go.
Fast.
- Can I really send you an email?
- You really can send me an email.
(crowd shouting)
- Don't tell anybody, I'm
trying to see how incognito.
(shouting)
- Appreciate it!
- Guys, I gotta go I'm gonna
miss this fucking flight.
Guys, I'm gonna miss this fucking flight.
- Keep that.
- Keep it thank you so much.
Thank you.
(audience shouting)
Thanks for coming, thank you for coming.
Thank you for coming, get home safe.
Thank you for coming, see ya.
Bye guys, bye.
See you guys, bye bye.
(applause)
Thank you, thank you.
Bye guys.
- Nice work, bud, I got everything.
Phew.
(laughter)
I gotta go catch my flight.
I love you, bro.
- Love you too, man.
Beautiful day, man.
- Thank you so much.
- [Crew] Airport Gary.
- Airport Gary.
I can walk a little bit if like.
- You wanna walk over there?
He's pullin up right there.
- Yeah, let's walk.
- I saw you in LA.
I told you I'd scrub your
floors with my toothbrush.
- Yes.
- And I emailed you and
emailed you and I was never
able to get in touch with you.
Is it still possible?
- It's still possible bro.
- How do I do this?
- Just fucking keep emailing me.
I promise, I'll go through it.
- I'll keep doing it.
- Please, that's the way to do it.
(shouting)
Whose birthday?
- Use it on my sister.
- Let's go.
- [Female Fan] Can I
get a picture for her?
- Let's do it.
- Thank you.
- [Young Rapper] I've got
some fire beats for your blog.
Yo, some beats for your vlog!
I watch them, I watch them every day.
- Thank you Gary.
- Caleb, beats.
- [Female Fan] You're awesome!
I got you.
- One, two, three.
(fans chatting)
- Real quick, real quick.
I'm really gonna miss this flight, fellas.
(shouting)
I will.
Let's go, let's go old school, baby.
- All right, one, two, three.
(music drowns out question)
- He goes through heavy on his DMs.
Heavy.
- Does he have Instagram, Twitter?
- Both, he goes through it heavy.
(music drowns out chatter)
I'm gonna answer eventually.
- (mumble) for a dollar, subject line.
- (mumble) with the Instagram like shit.
Like, you saw what they did?
- I'm about that, I'm about that.
It's something I've been talking about
for six months, which is
if you got rid of the likes
everybody would be in a much
better fucking place bro.
And this is somebody
who gets a lot of likes
but fuck it.
(mumbles)
Long term.
For real, it's real.
- Appreciate it, thank you.
- I've got three more, all
right two more two more.
- I know.
All right, I gotta go.
See ya, take care.
Thank you, good luck.
My pleasure.
- Oh wait.
- Sorry.
- [Young Rapper] You
gotta love my beats bro.
- I actually met you downtown in Huston.
- Oh hey, what's up?
- But quick quick.
- Thank you.
I gotta really really go.
Thank you bro.
- Thank you.
- Good to see you again, really quick.
You got it.
Okay, take care everyone.
We're done.
I love you, Dio.
See ya.
- [Caleb] Later, Dio.
- All right, off to Nashville.
Straight up, if you're watching this,
it'd mean so much to
me if you hit the bell,
hit the subscribe, like be part of this.
- [Caleb] Thank you.
(rhythmic beats)